people are running back we evacuate and
you know a big dramatic thing Jennifer
Lopez opens up about the massive power
outage in New York City on Saturday that
forced her to stop midway through her
it's my party tour stop and evacuate
Madison Square Garden this happened to
me one time at the Staples Center I was
performing with pitbull and all the
lights went out you know we had the same
thing and power outage and I just
thought it and it came on seven minutes
later and we kept going so when this
happened I was like okay let's just wait
a second it'll come back on and then
we'll just keep going and then you know
people are running back we evacuate was
a big dramatic thing hi guys so we're
backstage they just told me to get
offstage obviously all the power went
out in the city and obviously here at
Madison Square Garden well who hurt in
the middle of our show they're asking
everybody to evacuate very slowly and
calmly Jennifer rescheduled her show for
Monday and et was with the superstar
backstage she explained why it was so
important for her to make it up to her
fans I just felt like everybody came out
for this special celebration the the
crowd was so electric that night even
just for the first 15 minutes that they
got to see so I was like I just can't
leave it like that I don't want to leave
it like that they want the experience
that's what they came for and I want to
give it to them so I was like you know
what can we do can we do it tomorrow can
we do it the next day before we go to
Boston cuz we only had those those days
and they said we could try to make it
work for Monday and then thank God
everything worked out perfect
[Music]
[Music]
the energy was off the charts it was it
was it was just something special in the
air I think because we got interrupted
and it looked like it wasn't gonna
happen and it could have not happened
and then to be back here and for me to
be able to do this because same people
was just say it was just it was just it
was just electric it was really electric
and to do that here in New York was was
a super special
[Music]